hey everybody welcome to rollback where
we share the best conversations from our
pre-video catalog with you for the very
first time
today we're featuring tom hardin aka
tipperx
tom is a former wall street hedge fund
analyst turned fbi informant turned
global keynote speaker and his story is
just absolutely mind-blowing it's almost
as if it was ripped out of an episode of
billions
it goes like this
after succumbing to the temptations of
insider trading and getting caught tom
goes on to become one of the most
prolific fbi informants in securities
fraud history as this mysterious unnamed
tipper x and he spends years
documenting the illegal misdeeds of his
friends and his colleagues as this key
figure in the wall street house cleaning
campaign the fbi deemed operation
perfect hedge
and although he's since found a second
career second life as a successful
speaker
at the time of this conversation tom had
lost his job he'd lost his friends he'd
lost his standing in his community his
dream
his sense of self
and he found himself unemployable
wracked by guilt and basically alone
so i'm super honored that tom agreed to
sit down with me back then to trust me
which was just weeks after his
sentencing hearing to share for the very
first time on record the details behind
the choices he made the wreckage that it
caused and what he learned about himself
in the process
and with that i give you me in
conversation with tom harden
i just i can't even imagine what it
would be like to walk a mile in your
shoes so
i think it takes a little bit of courage
to come down here and
and share a little bit so thank you no
problem yeah pleasure to do it um
you know it's been i would imagine a
pretty crazy past couple weeks it was
february 25th right where you had your
sentencing hearings
and that's kind of the sort of closing
the book or the final chapter on what's
been a really long road for you it was
yes and uh we were pretty confident in
the outcome that i received but you
never know because
um the judge had not uh sentenced
anybody else in this uh
insider trading ring so we weren't sure
exactly what would happen would i get
probation or would you throw the book at
me or
i mean the possibility existed that you
still could go to jail go to jail right
yeah and so um i have you know a
five-year-old three-year-old wife
um so that was uh still a possibility
and
um even though the prosecution was
recommending probation no jailed the
probation officer was recommended the
same thing
she still uh took a few minutes to think
about it
a very pregnant pause she
heard everybody and said let me take a
few minutes i'm sort of thinking what is
there
there's no there's no like mandatory
sentencing there are mandatory
sentencing guidelines but they don't
have to stick by that and because of the
cooperation um they can send this below
that right so i was looking at if i
didn't cooperate i believe it was 36
months
of
incarceration and so
my cooperation then brings that down
right and it helped that the prosecution
was recommended yeah yeah they said this
was one of our star
cooperators and um he did so much for us
and
uh you know they didn't they weren't
recommending jail time or anything so
so
uh no jail time served uh
and
no probation are you you're not probably
not a probationary previous to this you
were just out on bail right right i had
um pleaded guilty in december 2009
and um i spent the day in the us
marshall's office being processed so i
was sentenced to time served a few weeks
ago which just meant that time i was
incarcerated for a few hours
right but over the last couple of years
um i've been waiting to be sentenced and
so it was kind of a probationary period
i talked to a probation officer a few
times why did it take six years to
sentence you i don't know um i i don't
think that was a high priority because
uh they were going after all that
backlogged i mean you're a high profile
guy yeah like everybody knew who you
were right right
it was uh
it just kept getting delayed i kept
getting a date um we get ready for it
and then a few weeks out um i learned it
was delayed and this was a process from
2000 i was in court 2009 i was to be
sentenced to 2010 it just took for
until 2015. so it was crazy at 37 now i
could be doing something totally i could
be in my second career already and right
i've lost the working years of 32 to 37
which are prime right right right
working years and i don't i can't retire
i mean i have to work yeah yeah yeah but
at least a sigh of relief yes over the
last couple weeks right yeah it's a huge
relief uh just getting it behind me
um
and i haven't been able to speak to many
of my friends in the industry for
several years and so is there a gag
order on you being able to talk to
people or how did that like how does
that work um most people didn't respond
to me um i would reach out uh when they
get together in the city and yeah yeah
you're i think you're a poison pill yeah
i think what the compliance officers
they probably i imagine my friends have
to tell their
employers
that they knew me and my name was in the
press and right like is this guy showing
up with a wire too yeah exactly so i
understood i didn't hold grudges like
why haven't you talked to me in five
years and i would probably have to do
the same thing if it was another friend
right but you have the felony conviction
i do yeah
so right so you have to figure out a way
to
you know move forward with that and
right i want to get into that but let's
take it back to the beginning like i
want to i want to understand
how this all began i mean you you're
you know as i understand it you were
raised in relatively middle class
circumstances you were able to get a uh
scholarship to wharton right did you do
bus school and undergrad as one program
one program right i received an rotc
scholarship which is the only real way
to get a scholarship at ivy
and so i went to the wharton
undergraduate program
um
you know good student in high school had
the grades
grew up where uh outside of atlanta
in a county called gwinnett like
northeast of atlanta it's a pretty
sprawling metropolitan area the
traffic's terrible
my father worked for coca-cola
my mother had a daycare center in our
home
just middle-class lifestyle i played
soccer i had two younger brothers we
were all soccer players
um it wasn't good enough to play at penn
i could have walked on but then
i looked at doing that my freshman year
and then the rigors of the academic load
right it wasn't worth it i was going to
be playing in mls or anything so it's
like a hybrid business school undergrad
program it is the business center so you
go right into b school right right you
go into you get a bs in economics and
you concentrate in finance or accounting
or whatever so it's a it's a bachelor's
so you knew
you knew when you were a kid you wanted
to go into finance yes yeah banker right
right i was always reading uh three
newspapers every morning at usa today
you're one of those guys one of those
alex p cadence
i was trying to remember his name from
from yeah yeah i didn't wear the suit at
school i didn't want to be hanging by
the flagpole
but uh yeah no i was just really into it
following it and uh what do you where
where do you think that came from
um i don't know my my grandmother was uh
a stock picker she got into it in the
60s and 50s and
i talked with her about the market when
i was a child and were you like trading
when you weren't hungry i wasn't no no
just but i would just follow it um and
then so when i got to senior year
the wharton school is the top business
program and that was my reach school
back you know in the 90s you'd be
applied to three schools right so yeah
yeah that was the reach
and um i got deferred and got wait
listed
and i kept peppering the admissions
officer with all my ap scores and sct 2s
and all that stuff and saying it's my
top choice
and we had no way to really pay for it
and then the the rotc scholarship came
over
and so that that kind of worked it out
what do you have to do to like you have
to you have to be par what is being in
the rotc involved so it was uh one day a
week
of class and then there was a drill
a couple hours after that so it was like
one friday i had to go to another
university in philadelphia saint
joseph's
and i do that every uh every friday for
four years and then are you in the
reserves after that or so what happened
was um it was 1999 i did an internship
um actually with donaldson left in
generat in 1998 in the summer in l.a
they were the ballers yeah yeah it was
the ex struck so lambert guys guys that
didn't get caught up and all that stuff
so right
so yeah if you're familiar um so i got
that summer 1998 internship it was like
we're going out every night it was a
great right and you're in the thick of
it there yeah yeah i mean not that la is
the center of finance but dlj in l.a was
a was a major reality yeah yeah yeah
yeah they had a couple of were you was
that century city yes yes fox plaza i
worked in the fox plaza yeah
what year was that uh i was there in the
summer 98 and i started working there in
the fall of 99. we were there we were
working in that building at the same
time well we really okay i was a lawyer
at christensen miller in 98
and 99. yeah 98.99 i was there yeah
every day working i lived in the last 24
24th floor i think i can't remember yeah
i don't know where the floor i was on
but uh
i i graduated penn i bought a jeep and
drove out to la and
lived in westwood there at ucla and i
just got that's what everybody does when
they're when they're new to l.a they
think westwood's a place
yeah
i was shocked up in the library
this is the way to live so i lived in
westwood but i didn't see any of it
because that you know that program in
investment banking is 100 hour work
weeks or more and right
uh you're not you're twiddling your
thumbs during the day and at five
o'clock in the afternoon the managing
director says i need this in my chair in
the morning mm-hmm and so you're there
all night for life yeah i bet you we
rode the elevator at the same time
probably you know probably that's a trip
yeah so you do that and uh
you're setting your sights on wall
street yeah getting to new york at some
point in my career and then uh
january 2000 um i get a call from a
friend who's at a hedge fund
which is a small investment firm
in greenwich connecticut saying they're
looking uh and this is at the time
january 2000 the nasdaq is going crazy
the valuations are very frothy in these
um
toys.com and pets.com and rights.com so
when i came back after the first bubble
yeah the first the summer of 98
everybody i came back to work with in
the fall 99 was gone they were all the
dot coms
so i didn't really know as many people
there and
got this call it sounded pretty sexy
covered technology stocks at this hedge
fund that was growing in greenwich
connecticut
and so in january 2000 i flew from l.a
to greenwich connecticut and snows
everywhere
i don't know if i made the right
decision yeah
but um but it's something i wanted to
eventually get to in my career and so i
figured at 22
uh when i would not start and that was
lenexa uh that was called um blair asset
management okay so that's your first job
like first job like picking stocks yeah
right i was invested making just for a
few months
so came over to start picking uh to get
trained to pick technology stocks for
this firm
um so i worked there a couple years um
spent a lot of time in silicon valley
that's where all the companies are and
right
developing relationships there
doing uh fundamental research
when you pick a stock a technology you
want to talk to the customers the
suppliers
the competitors and develop
a view on the stock do you want to own
it or do you want to short it because in
the hedge fund you can be short or you
can be long
so i did that
like boots on the ground researching yes
exactly yeah it's
right like kind of what i learned in
school and
um fundamental analysis they called it
not not trading technical analysis
fundamental
um you know peter lynch is a name for
the analysis um
and so that was in 2000
that firm closed in 2002 but i bounced
around between other firms that were
similar
2003 2004 so in my 20s i had the same
type of job at different firms right
and then i got up
into 2006
and a friend of mine was starting a fund
lenexa
and
said you know do you want to come join
me as a partner and so
i said sure you know i know i had
partnership anywhere before and i was
coming to my late 20s and i had several
years of experience and this is a great
opportunity to to see something grow and
maybe this would be my
my job i could hold until retirement
right right right well you're getting in
at the this was just beginning right so
you get on the ground floor right
so just walk somebody walk walk the
audience through what a hedge fund is
and what a hedge fund does just for the
lay person right so a hedge fund is a
pool of
capital
from investors that can be institutional
or individual
the hedge fund can
invest it's different from a mutual fund
because not only can it buy stocks they
can short stocks which means you bet the
stocks uh shares of this company are
going to go down
um and so in theory no matter what the
market does
as long as you're owning the right
stocks you're betting that the right
stocks are going to go up and you're
betting against the right stocks you're
betting those are going to go down you
should be making money
whether the market's going crazy or the
market's tanking
and so
because that's a it's a
i guess viewed as a higher skill set
than the mutual fund the the funds that
the the firm can charge are are higher
the
profit percentages are higher right so
the hedge fund would keep
um 20 of all profits and 80 percent go
to investors
so it gets pretty lucrative based on how
many assets you have
how much
you can return and then you take your 20
and this is why yeah so you take your 20
no matter what right right so that's
pretty good right well you think you're
uh it's two percent management which is
charged on the size of the fund and
twenty percent if you make money i
gotcha so if you're a big firm not
making money you're still taking your
two percent taking your assets right
and so this is why suddenly there's this
massive proliferation of hedge funds yes
money was going into hedge funds like
crazy in the last decade and
by 2005 2006 with housing going
that asset class was really uh on fire
and you could get into a hedge fund
it used to be you had to have a million
net worth and then it even became like
you could get into a fund of funds that
would invest in the hedge fund if you
didn't have that so
there was a lot of money going into it
right so there's there's you would
invest in like if you're an individual
investor you could invest in a huge fund
and that fund would then invest in a
variety of hedge funds they would pick
hedge funds for you right so you get hit
with fees twice so
you have to
it's like if you're an individual it's
like leasing a car you're getting
screwed either way right exactly and and
what distinguishes one one hedge fund
from another other than the size of the
fund it's it's just the the managerial
team right
and what they're deciding to place their
style of investing
um how they do their research but it
becomes tougher to distinguish yourself
and grow as we learn because there's so
many funds and so if you meet with a
potential investor they say well what is
your what is your edge what do you what
can you
you own apple what do you know about
apple that nobody else knows i mean this
is
multiple this is one of the biggest this
is the biggest technology company what
can you tell me that nobody else knows
and
how do you answer that well we think
we're you know thematic investors and we
think apple is the tech stock to own for
the next 10 years because of they've got
mobile right they're going to get
wearables right
and we invest and we think that they're
going to earn
this much money in five years and the
stock's only trading here and they have
this much cash you try to justify it
based on your fundamental research
but that fundamental research is what's
accessible to everybody yes yeah so it
gets a little trickier so really you
have to put up consistently good returns
and
if you do that for you for a few years
um
most people wouldn't stop asking
questions and right but when you first
begin you have to build that trust
something right right so you need at
least one big investor who's going to
say i'm going to take a bet on these
young guys right and so you become like
this that what was called one of the
tiger cubs right you need a big anchor
and there um
julian robertson started tiger this was
a big hedge fund
uh started in the early 80s and became a
big fund through the 90s tiger tiger
management along with soros management
these were george soros julian robertson
billionaires now multi-billionaires and
um
julian started seeding
uh younger managers um
later in life and so he wanted to just
to find the next him or the next
guys that would carry the torch for him
and so
he we started off with 16 million he
gave us 15.
another individual gave us a million so
we had 16 million dollars but we did
have him
as our anchor investor
and uh then we could go out to potential
other investors and at least we got this
guy we've got this guy
for us you've heard of them yeah yeah
uh-huh and so i mean 16 million is not
that's a small fund right and yeah and
so you're this upstart
fund and how large you know how large
did it get we got to 100 million in 2007
so through um capital appreciation and
bringing in more investors
we had a great uh 2007 as did many funds
and so what happens is a lot of these
investors wait to see how you do and
then they put money in
you know at the end of 2007
right which is like buying a stock at
the top right right so
so the first couple the first year and a
year or whatever you so this is good
right yeah you're like living your dream
right a partner at hedge fund see it by
julian robertson
um you know i'm 2
8 years old and
this is kind of where i'm going to see
myself staying and maybe eventually
he'll give me money for my own hedge
fund and right maybe i'll just be doing
this for you
you're very well positioned for like a
really lucrative successful career right
and are you married yeah when did you
yes i got married i'm very really young
i was like 27 right um but my wife um
we met in 2003 at a bar through mutual
friends but uh
and she uh she was actually a swimmer at
harvard oh wow yeah yeah cool so she's
the real athlete of the family and i
just tacked on like
that's interesting yeah who is the coach
there joe bernal didn't coach the women
there uh
stuff stuff reid is the coach now and
coached
my wife um back in the 90s
but i think she just i think she's been
there 15 years but i don't remember who
the men's
yeah which was joe bernal i think he's
still there
anyway um but you
what's interesting is that
it seems to me my impression from the
limited amount of articles on the web
about this is that you seem like overall
you're a pretty grounded guy like you're
not you're not like living the ball or
lifestyle like getting some huge loft in
tribeca no no i mean like you're living
in new jersey and you're building your
family
yeah family not not balling in the club
right throwing dollars
but you must have like lots of you you
must have buddies do i mean yes talk
talk to me about like the culture of
that world like yeah typical hedge fund
guy they were going down new york uh
multiple times a week um
pulling in like what you know what yeah
what does it look like uh
i mean you know 24 25 year old guys
pulling in a couple of million dollars a
year maybe right or at least a couple
hundred thousand so they've got no no
kids no wife they're just
pulling them big bucks for that age and
and just throwing them just like crazy
traveling to vegas let's go to vegas
this weekend
yeah let's go to ibiza like how are you
like are you just opting out of that or
yeah i understand the margins of it or a
little bit like i go to vegas here and
there if it was like a bachelor party
for a good friend go out but
i wasn't too much into that partying all
the time and i was pretty serious about
my work right because it's like you know
for most people i mean i have friends
that are in this world so i know a
little bit about it and i wouldn't say
that i'm very well versed in it and you
know it's like you know our point of
reference is wolf of wall street right
wall street what you see in the movies
or what you see in television like when
you when you see something like that
like when you watch a movie like that do
you
do you go us no it's not like that or do
you go yeah like i can you know i know
guys like that or i mean not exactly
like that but like that yeah there's
guys like that yeah but it's not i
wouldn't say the average guy is like
that um
but uh yeah people are definitely i mean
at that age when you're making that kind
of money right they're just spending it
and having fun and it's going to last
forever and right well i mean you know
it's sort of like when everyone balks at
how justin bieber acts but it's like
throw that much money at any kid that
age and see what happens you know what
it means like people become you know
a little bit different versions of maybe
what they would be they yeah you know
we're surrounded by grounded people or
whatever right right i had like a middle
class upbringing
um a lot of guys i met you know it's
sort of like the prep school mafia
where'd you go and i went to a good
college but i was public high school and
and so not being in that circle i think
i just wasn't into right the pinky ring
yeah yeah exactly
right right yeah uh-huh interesting all
right so so where does it start to
you know begin to unravel i mean at some
point
you know somebody enters your orbit and
you make a regrettable decision right
and cross a certain line
uh around 2005 2006 um
i go to a lot of investment stock
investment conferences so what that
means is a bank will put on a conference
and bring their clients there
who are public companies and
they give their presentations their
power points q a
and they have meetings with investors
and so you go there you meet with the
companies that you know and then
you're talking to them about all their
businesses
and then at night you're going out with
your buddies who are also investors
and so
2006 really
at these dinners people are talking
about
oh so-and-so is going to buy so-and-so
next week oh yeah i know that one but
i'm going to play this other one you
know about this company is going to buy
this one
and i'm sitting there and
all year 2006 i kind of can't believe
that people are
just doing it so blatantly and
putting bets on um takeovers and
whatnot and so
i guess everybody kind of went to school
together and some people are investors
some are lawyers but they're all
kind of um this cabal yeah yeah so all
my buddies like uh or he works at this
technology company and he gives me the
numbers
and i'm kind of like what do you mean he
gives you the numbers oh he tells me the
revenue and the gross margin in the
earnings before it's probably before
it's public
and so some you know we play that one
small and we'll play another one big and
if you buy a stock big sell some before
the announcement because that way
if the sec calls you
oh i was selling some like i didn't know
that was going to happen
and so it's i'm here but as long as you
don't play it too big and you mix it up
with some other stuff right yeah you
want to get flagged yeah and if you do
at least you're saying oh i was selling
it the day before or right or hey you're
only calling me about this big winner
look at all these big losings trades i
have like
what are you talking about so but
clearly there's a lot of this
information getting yeah clearly it's
over there
a little bit like
you know as as someone on the outside
looking in like
it's easy to be kind of flabbergasted
like really but you know when you're
immersed in the culture to just be kind
of like well this is going on right
right it's going on i'm going to these
conferences i'm going to to dinner with
buddies in new york
oh what are you playing next week i'm
playing the takeover of this company
buying that company
and i didn't
i was just sort of shocked like it was
so blatant but it's been going on at
that point for the whole year 2006.
funds are being started whose business
models are just
crossing the line and playing these
deals
like for example like explain that a
little bit um like uh there were people
in the industry
managing small hedge funds
who uh became known for um
just playing uh meaning they were just
placing bets
on
either
certain companies earnings announcements
because they had contacts in those
companies
or they had
lawyer contacts would tell them
about mergers and acquisition deals and
said they would play those i'm being
placed place bets on the stocks
and so that was if you looked at a lot
of the firms 2005 2006 a lot of their
big winners were illegal trades
in this type of uh
off of inside information right and
they're getting away with that they're
getting away with it it's not being uh
prosecuted at all as far as i could see
and
uh i think in the early part of the
decade the focus was maybe on boiler
room stuff and
the you know long island stock broker
and stuff like that
penny stocks right the wolf of wall
street type situation it wasn't really
on this higher level
big hedge fund small hedge funds doing
all this
uh like moving huge amounts of money
around yeah yeah
um and so that was going on pretty
blatantly all of 2006
[Music]
the biggest analogy that i can think of
is
doping and cycling like there's a
culture where this is just going on and
you know again uh to be the outsider
looking in it's sort of like shocking
but when you're in the middle of it it's
you could see how
you're gonna start to gravitate towards
making that choice if that's what's
going on around you i mean is that how
you would characterize that i think
that's pretty close like i was thinking
steroids in baseball same type of thing
um
if you uh
were in high school an ap calculus and
somebody said hey here's the answers to
the test
you're not really looking to find the
answers to the test but somebody just
gave them to you
even if you're the most ethical person
you have the test the next day and
somebody just gave you the answers it's
going to be hard not to
do something with that so
yeah having the answers to the test
doping and cycling or steroids and
baseball but there's a like i guess the
difference between steroids or doping
and this would be
you know you could just be
within a group of people and passively
absorb something without taking any
action like suddenly you've just
overheard something and and then you
have this moral dilemma like well can i
i could act on that i just overheard
this i was at a cocktail party and i
heard these guys talking about this
you have to take the action of acting on
it but you you've come into that
information passively whereas like you
know taking steroids that's a
that's a you know a conscious act that
you have to take so but at some point
you do take a conscious like you
you
do you remember like what was it like
when you consciously said i'm gonna take
this step i'm going to step over the
line like what was that yeah it was in
2007 so i was saying 2006 was getting
pretty crazy with the stuff in 2007
a woman who i had known through the
industry was also an investor
she was one of these people um who
always heard a lot of rumors
and so
she would call me a lot of times with
you know i hear a rumor about intel's
everything's going to be good you should
be buying it and sometimes she's wrong
and it's like right roomie con yes
that's right um and so she called me one
day and said
um i'm hearing uh our
i'm being told that kronos is going to
be acquired
next week for i forgot the dollar amount
and that's a little different than uh oh
i'm hearing uh this and that did you
wait so did you call her or she could
she called you she's like this she she's
like this intermediary like a an
information warehouse for passing this
stuff along right she lives in silicon
valley and atherton big house
made a bunch of money and so she is
really plugged into those that that
network of people
um and how did you initially get
connected with her um a mutual uh
investor friend of ours several years
before connected me with her i'd
actually never met her in person
for five or six years and so we just
talked on the phone
and so she was always meeting with
companies meeting with her friends that
worked at these companies and trying to
piece things together
i mean legitimately most of the you know
most of the time but
um
it got to the point in 2007 where
she called me with the information about
uh this takeover and it was very
specific but it was the first time so i
don't know if it's a rumor or
uh you know
sure okay i'll buy a little bit i mean
who would have the specific information
and she never had any information that
specific uh
and so um
my funds
we bought a little bit of shares
relative to our asset size it wasn't
like we were saying oh let's make a big
bet on this right but do you do you kind
of privately harbor this or do you tell
your partners no i told my partner yeah
like uh she caught she talked to her
this is what she's saying so there's a
collective decision here to like right
on this right i hope maybe he would say
yeah you know right
and he and did you kind of have like a
you know what was the mental calculus
like were you aware like okay i'm i'm
making this making this decision
moral dilemma that i'm gonna fall into
that i'm gonna sort of take a step into
the dark side yeah it was like that um
hearing all those guys in 2006 bragging
about these big trades and they know
this and that
hey finally like
you know tom doing the real fundamental
work talking to customer suppliers
that's all
you know finally i'm getting one of
these
yeah i'm getting one of these the hot
ones
and so there was something like finally
you're on the team yeah i'm on the team
so like if i see these guys again at
dinner hey did you guys hear about this
one like no
uh and so yeah so there was that
decision
uh that was i mean when you like so when
you go home that night knowing that that
trade's happening like how does that
like is it are you just cool with it or
is it like creating some dissonance for
you or like how does that how do you
emotionally kind of process that or does
it just be it just is you rationalize it
this is the way the business is that was
the first one so it was just
rationalized maybe it's a rumor maybe
uh nothing's going to happen um but
at the same time saying hey it's my turn
to take a few crumbs off the table
um you don't really think about it is
hey i'm going to come in a felony like
there's no there's no victims the
victims are the public the investing
public doesn't know this so
but there's not really it's not a
white-collar crime where oh i'm going to
like build these guys out of their money
like it's not yeah there's there's
arguments that you can use to
rationalize it yeah exactly and and the
idea of like hey if i really want to
play in this field like i've got to step
it up got to do this yeah so they do
some of these and
and so how much money did the fund make
off that trade uh that one we i think we
made like half a million dollars which
on a hundred million dollars um point
five percent so it's not i mean it was a
good trade that day but
it's not something we needed to do
because 2007 we're doing we're doing
well anyways right
but so we made a decent decent chunk of
money um there and so and now you're in
now i'm in um and
rumi says hey this guy that gave me the
information i gave him your cell phone
number
he wants to get paid
and then i know
you did what oh my god you gave this so
you're not paying no one's paying roomie
but she wants to pay her sources yeah he
wants to get paid uh i think ten
thousand dollars is good could you write
him a check
i'm going to write him a check from my
bank account to some guy i don't even
know then i know i'm really like
this is way overboard right like oh my
god like
i can't believe this is happening uh
but then i'm already in we've already
played the stock and
if you so the the implicit understanding
is if you want this channel of
communication to stay open you got to
take care of she's saying you got to
take care of it this guy's going to have
a few more for us i think
so let's give them
let's get them going now and he'll have
a few more
um so what do you do so get cash out or
whatever i had shared um
this information with another friend in
another fund
and i asked him do you think you could
get some cash together for my source
because he's going to have a few more
for us so i was kind of the intermediary
so it wouldn't nothing would be coming
from me
uh and my friend got cashed together he
worked at the trading desk where a bunch
of traders had made money and they said
they they wouldn't pass the hat
they got 10 grand
and then this guy
roomy's friend is going to be in new
york
he texts me meet me at so-and-so corner
and it's sort of i have the envelope and
i don't look at him and
are you tom and i hold it up
and he just takes it out of your hand
you're on a street corner in new york
right are you tom
wow
hold it up there's the money and
i i kind of try to disassociate myself
from it like i'm not really doing this
like uh
i don't know like this isn't me but i
play in the game now and so right right
right i'll give him the money and
uh maybe maybe he will just go away and
not uh
not give us anything anymore maybe this
will be it and i'll just take a shower
and
yeah
yeah uh you know the human
ability to rationalize you know behavior
is profound right right like you've
already you've already did it you've got
to get through the day this is what's
happening and to disassociate like who
you are from
the action that you're taking is the
only way that you can kind of
live with the behavior right right right
yeah so interesting
um
you know this interview came together
like sort of super last minute and uh
uh so i didn't read up as much as maybe
i could have i mean i you know i know
your story but
i'm remembering
uh maybe i'm totally wrong about this
but i believe there was a vanity fair
article like a while back that that
roomy it was about just kind of what's
going on in hedge funds and about i
think there was stuff about this case in
particular the galleon case in
particular
but i believe there was some stuff about
roomie and what she was doing maybe
there was something in the new york
times weekend magazine a few weeks ago
about what she's up to she went to
prison for a year
and what she's up to out of prison and
my name was in there
from what i understood the the fbi had
approached her
around 2007 um with a list of names and
she was instrumental to their
prosecution of the galleon group right
which is the big billionaire they were
going after that they put away for 11
years
she happened to only be talking to this
billionaire me and another guy i was on
a short list and i'm a no nobody
compared to
right so you're probably assuming she's
she's making all kinds of calls to every
like all right right you're just a small
fish in her little like i don't want to
know who she's talking to it's better
not to know
and i come after
all this happened i come to realize
she's really not talking to too many
people
so when they're trying to get leverage
on raj rajaratnam
rumi khan is feeding him information
with a few stocks who else is rumi khan
talking to how can we get leverage on
her
oh there's this guy tom hardin like this
guy
right so that's how it all begins right
but back to
you know kind of the timeline so you do
this so the chronos trade is the first
thing and then from it just goes from
there right it goes from there the next
one is um hilton july 4th 2007. so they
were they were going to be acquired by
blackstone right right um so you come
into that information right through
roomie again through roomie uh hilton's
going to buy blackstone uh blackstone's
gonna buy hilton um
july it's gonna happen july third at
this price
and so at that point
i'm thinking of how can i justify this
trade if the sec ever calls me about
these trades so i'm looking i'm looking
at options activity sometimes the
options on the stock start
people start buying options because they
know something or
nothing's going on
the date july third an analyst from a
bank puts out a report saying hilton
could be a good takeover target because
it's cheap mm-hmm i tell my partner we
can buy this stuff hang your hat on that
yeah this is a report it's actually
going to happen tonight like it's going
to happen before the like the holiday
tomorrow
we can buy all we want today because
this report's out thank god we have like
a cover mm-hmm and so
he agreed and we bought hilton and but
you went large on that one a little bit
bigger because we had had uh the
information
we had gone through the kronos trade and
okay hilton
we know it's like how much time in
between these two trades uh
chronos was in march and hilton was july
so a couple months
and we went bigger in that one and we
had this cover
there's this analyst report
if we ever got called by the sec because
we had heard
in the past that funds
uh who have questionable trades usually
get like a nice phone call from the sec
hey could you call us back and talk to
us about this okay let's get our cover
ready and
as long as you can show them your
profits and like hey you guys aren't
asking me about all these trades i lost
money on here i lose money i make money
you can call me about my winners look at
my losers and it usually passes if you
can dance around it
um so we had to cover for hilton right
so like if the initial red flag goes up
you get that courtesy call right you're
organized about right why are you buying
your technology hedge fund like right
right right right right right right
right right well it's not a tech stock
right why are you buying it the day
before it's being acquired oh this guy
you know
we might even i think i don't know if we
did but you might even buy hilton
marriott you might buy all three or four
public insured ones just say oh we're
making a bet i got you yeah yeah so the
strategies for just hiding it or
constantly thinking of a cover mm-hmm
right and then after hilton uh was uh
you don't you're not getting any of
these phone calls
sec is not no no
yeah no even after
right
radio silence it's radio i think you're
in the clear right uh
everybody else is kind of doing their
own takeover trades my other investor
friends
everybody's just playing the games 2007
we call it merger monday you wake up
every monday there's three or four
mergers that we're negotiating over the
weekend
it's just a pretty frothy
and then the next trade was the google
earnings announcement in july
it was from a different contact of
roomies
she worked at an investor relations firm
and
new
was privy to google's
revenue and earnings per share and knew
the exact information
so we
google was actually going to come up
short of what wall street was estimating
google was on the stock was going up a
lot because it was internet was hot and
all that and they were actually going to
miss their quarterly estimates which
never happened
so there was going to be a big short
opportunity here
on the stock
so we shorted the stock based on that
information and she was correct all the
numbers were perfect
[Music]
and so bad against google the market
went down the next day
google missed earnings
uh we knew about it right we made that
trade so you're three for three right
and she had told me before that this
contact wanted fifteen thousand dollars
uh she was gonna be somebody else we're
gonna have all our sources paid we're
gonna have this other guy this woman
and so so it's really like this network
is forming of how you're going to
continue to be able to do this you're
creating systems around right managing
it right and it kind of passed the shock
of giving that money to people like okay
i'll tell you you're just acclimating
that this is yeah there's no business as
usual you might if i tell this this guy
this trading firm because they'll they
pass the hat and they'll give me the
money i don't have to write a check
so i can just let them they make their
money and then pass it to her
like sure no problem
so then i see uh so another envelope on
the street corner about in california
silicon valley at a tech stock
conference room he's there and
here's the 15 in an envelope is it is
cash yeah
i'm actually um
like i'm on the plane
going out to san francisco it's in my
back pocket it's 15 grand i put it
didn't fit in my two back pockets i had
to put in all my pockets into my jeans
go through security fine you have to put
it in the bucket when you go through
security so
no it's in my pockets what happened was
uh
so then i run to the bathroom put it on
my carry-on
i'm going in it's in a bank envelope
going on the plane to san francisco
excuse me sir i was doing random
uh checks and bags
like all right if they find it i'm going
i'm going to vegas i'm going to go san
francisco i'm going to vegas that's why
i'm bringing all this cash because if
you have over 10 you have to declare
right or you have to declare it because
it could be drug trafficking or whatever
or
they could take it i think if it's over
10 oh wow so there's 15 tsa is going
through my bag
uh the lady sees the envelope
and she just keeps going and says all
right she doesn't open the envelope
like wow wow yeah so
i get on the plane like i'm thinking
what am i doing like yeah this is i mean
is that is that what do you start
questioning like i mean is there a
moment where you're like i got to stop
this or you're just too in i'm just too
weak
i don't know if i'm like
not having fun with that but kind of
like the clandestine and like
moving the money and doing this stuff
and it's kind of claws in you yeah yeah
i'm like oh this i'm not hurting anybody
like this is just
something everybody else is doing i
justify it by uh it seems like everybody
else is doing it at the time and
uh and no no phone calls from the sec no
there's no indication that anybody's
paying attention no it's not being
checked it's july 2007 right so it's
nothing's going on all right so how many
more of these before we get to the point
where this starts to unravel there's one
more um so
my buddy at the trading firm who i had
been passing the roomie con tips to give
me one back in september
uh 3com was going to be acquired by bain
capital out of boston in september
and
and so that happened uh
and that was the last one so there was
four trades four um
and so i think we bought half a million
shares it was a three or four dollar
stock but we still made a good chunk of
money on that
um and then that was uh nobody had to be
paid off for that that was kind of a
payback for the other three
and then that was it september october
2007
those four trades are done
all successful all profitable every time
roomies on point right and and and so
your fund ends up uh
coming out of this like 1.7 million
right right
uh and how much of that are you taking
home yourself uh three percent so
whatever that uh
uh
whatever that is a couple hundred
thousand yeah um because of the 20
um i had uh
15 percent of the 20 so three percent of
the overall
profits um
uh so that was the compensation for that
year right and are you looking over your
shoulder thinking like any moment this
is gonna come apart or are you thinking
oh this is
this is like you know easier than i
thought um
it's easier than i thought uh
we had a big
christmas holiday party at the 2007
seven to celebrate the firm i got i got
a couple toasts
uh we had a great 2007 and
uh it wasn't until uh i believe it was
january 2008 where i got a call from
rumi
um
saying that the sec had called her
um about uh one of those trades i don't
remember which one
and uh what do you think we should tell
them for a cover story hmm at that point
i'm starting a little nervous because uh
right why would they call her about
something that you did right they must
be putting the pieces together right are
they
why would they call an intermediary who
who on her own was not making any trades
unless they were well she was trading
information she had her own account
right she didn't have a fund but she had
her own personal stock account so she
was trading all the stocks she was pax
and me
so she said the sec called her about
trade she had placed i see one of these
four trades that we had done she
had received a phone call and and then
uh
she was asking me um
you know hey they mentioned your name
and
uh you know what should we tell them
like what would be our cover story and
i'm going to be in new york in a few
weeks we should meet up and figure out
what to tell them and so
i immediately get to work um we had the
cover story for hilton and then
kind of tried to figure out what were
the other cover stories be for chronos
and google and 3com and
i got something together i don't know if
it was um
analyst reports or
i believe kronos was going to be talking
at a stock conference
a few days after we bought so we could
say hey we were buying it because we
thought they would sound good at the
stock conference
um so i had something put together when
she came to new york
um and uh
she said i don't think it's going to be
a big deal they're just asking me about
these trades like uh
you know what should we tell them and
at that point i don't know if she's
wearing a wire on me or what's going on
i'm not even thinking about the wire
thing because i this
i haven't been approached by the fbi yet
and
so she's just asking me uh
what she should tell the sec and
so i
tell her
you know what i think she should say
here's our cover stories and i'm
starting to get pretty nervous because
it sounds like she's not in a good
situation and
um a little bit i know she really talks
to a few people so
right you're assuming she's talking to
all kinds of people yeah yeah right so
you're starting to think
this isn't good this isn't good but it
probably won't get back to me because
uh
she'll she'll be able to get out of this
and it's just the sec and
she'll figure out what to say right
now but now you're starting to look over
your shoulder a little bit more yeah
yeah in early 2008. i mean how does that
you know does that start affecting your
sleep like how does that work uh
not so much yeah i'm kind of
nervous i don't want i want to do every
trade by the book in early 2008 just my
own fundamental research
the market's getting pretty bad in the
first quarter 2008 everything's starting
to unravel
so we're actually as a firm we're
struggling
just with our portfolio it's very
stressful because of that
and then there's added stress of
kind of looking over my shoulder maybe
something's
uh
you know what if
we were to get a phone call about what
we say and
so that's happening through the early
part of 2008 and we're just not doing
well as a firm so it's very stressful
and um
you know it's the worst market in 75
years so it's the worst i've ever seen
yeah and you're trying to play it
straight now yeah yeah we're just
sticking by uh and your partners as well
yeah yeah we're not looking for any more
of these like
uh
kind of feeling guilty about it i think
and then you get the tap on the shoulder
uh so july uh
july 7 2008 a tuesday
where i the tuesday after july 4th
i'm dropping my dry cleaning off we left
at 55th and broadway
dropping my dry cleaning off come back
out
and then
somebody says are you tom i turn around
i see like a man and a woman in dark
suits
badge comes out
and um
yeah like oh uh the fbi would ask you a
few questions can we just go in this
wendy's here and sit down
so i sit down with them it's kind of
like uh
a little bit surreal like uh my heart's
pounding starting to pound a little bit
and
maybe they're just going to ask me about
roomie or something like it's not going
to be
me and
uh
they're not arresting you they're not
throwing you in a
but like is it like the movies feds with
the sunglasses
yeah yeah like i mean the dark trench
coats and dark suits right right dark
suits uh
you know flipping the wall and open fbi
just want to talk to you about a few
things right sure like where do you want
to talk let's
talk about it and
they start talking about hey we know
where you were
last weekend you were down seeing your
family uh you know your newborn nephew
in georgia and uh we know this and that
we know you know this person that person
we know we did these trades and that we
could play it for you if you wanted to
we have your voice recorded
scare tactics and then
it's like one of those scenes where i
could see their mouths moving i don't
hear what they're saying i'm just sort
of looking looking around and did they
have that or that's just a tactic to try
it out they had all that information
about all that i don't know if they
actually they're tapping your phone or
like i didn't make them play what they
had i just believe that they had it yeah
um and so
uh their mouths are moving i'm not
really processing it and
sort of snap out of it and they're
talking about
you can either help us or we can arrest
you now
um you know really laying it down on me
uh
so hey guys i'll help you like whatever
you want like yeah this is all true like
i
right i i
so there's no like i got to call my
lawyer no it wasn't any of that yeah it
wasn't like let me get back to you can i
get your card and call you in 24 hours
like
i was just sort of in a daze their
mouths are moving i'm thinking about
the last couple of months and year and
like hey i'll help you like what do you
need like
uh they talk about the big ring they're
trying to bust and
i'll do what i can
uh to help you out and so it's great you
know that's uh
that's your that's the best decision you
can make and
uh
well it's certainly the decision they
want you to be yes exactly right right
because they know you're they've got you
over a barrel you know
they know what you were doing but
they're not really concerned about you
they're going after raj right right
so explain a little bit about like who
raj is and galion right they uh
galion group was a big technology
focused hedge fund
raj
had a lot of investors who worked in
silicon valley
and so
he was
had the reputation to be
someone who would get
maybe better information about companies
because he had investors who worked at
those companies so they were
incentivized to give him
good information about their companies
and so they had a reputation of
being one of these funds maybe crossing
the line and
probably were under the uh i'd imagine
we're under the regulatory radar for
years just because of those
those relationships and
because of um some of the trades they
had done were
you know in these big takeovers and but
i don't think
i guess they were never really able to
nail him on anything up until then right
and it what's going on right now
in in uh kind of law enforcement in new
york city in the sec and everything like
that is that you have a highly motivated
us attorney right like preet bharara
right is like all about it yeah like
this is like
the mandate these are the places they
can win yeah and and trying to clean
house in the securities industry is like
a major sort of focus of this us
attorney right that's right yeah so it's
kind of like whatever you need all the
resources you know at this u.s
attorney's disposal to like make all
this happen yeah they had started
working on operation perfect hedge 2006
i think
and they had been hearing about these
this type of information going on but
they
needed
co-operators to wear
wires so they could wire top phones it's
very hard to get permission to wiretap
the phones and
so they were looking to use mafia type
tactics to to bust this ring
um
they i guess
at first wanted to maybe send an
undercover agent to work at the funds
but the funds are so the relationships
are so tightly knit that you can't
really put an agent in there like you
could maybe in a boiler room um like it
wouldn't work so they needed
co-operators smaller people that they
could
scare and then get to wear a wire and
then
get permission to wire tap the phones
right so that's where you come in this
is what they want you to do little fish
right so you have this meeting with the
fbi i mean how long does this meeting go
for i think it was like an hour but it
seemed like all day and then like so
they're like okay and then the meeting's
over like and what are you sitting at
wendy's by yourself
i'm like all right i'm gonna go to the
office what are you gonna do now yeah so
i walk out like i almost stepped in
front of a cab like i'm
just sort of delirious like you call
your wife i mean i just go to the office
because the market's about to open at 9
30 my partner is probably wondering
where i am
um so i get a little bit late sorry this
and that whatever
um
and so i have this business card
and i'm supposed to call them back to so
that they make sure that i'm going to be
a cooperator and help them out so i
think about it i don't i don't tell
anybody i don't tell my wife
um
later on i was told i could tell like my
wife my therapist my priest but that's
it you know
um
which
i didn't tell her till later
so
i decided let me call them and tell them
i'm fully on cooperation it seems like
this would be my best chance to stay out
of jail i don't know how this is going
to go down i don't know how big it is
they don't really show me the names i
just see a big ring they show me and
like okay
i can probably and you don't try to
negotiate at all and say
look i'm going to help you out but you
got to make sure that you know
i'm taken care of or i'm not
you're just you're just all in and you
don't even call a lawyer you know you're
not bringing a lawyer into this equation
at all i hired a that was um i was
approached in july 2008 by the fbi i
hired a lawyer in may of or april of
2009.
my lawyer couldn't believe that i had
cooperated for a year without any legal
counsel which is highly highly unusual
but that that may have played into you
know everything i mean
by all accounts you are you know
extraordinarily cooperative and that
really determined you know the
sentencing right yes that's right so it
actually helped not to
uh to cooperate would you recommend that
to be
erstwhile listener who's expecting a tap
on the shoulder
for you up and coming uh insider traders
yeah
you might want to take 24 hours to
consult an attorney just uh
because we maybe could have spun this as
oh
tom thought these were rumors like i
wasn't actually talking to anybody at
these companies i was talking to roomie
who's a rumor monker
but looking at like if you had you chose
to fight this and say arrest me you know
yeah if i had played not guilty let's go
to trial i'd be personally bankrupt uh
and then be in jail right now because
the hit rate was a hundred percent for
people going to trial
i think the jury has just looked at
these guys and said wall street's come
and blame them for what happened in 2008
when really
uh these were cases i think that the u.s
attorney knew they could win they were
going to go after the heads of the bank
selling bad mortgages because you can't
it's harder to win and right so these
were the faces raj raj ratnam's the face
of the financial
downfall which isn't really he was doing
bad stuff but it's not
it's not the guy that caused the market
to crash in 2008. but there was cases
they could win i think so
all right so suddenly you're an
informant right and you're harboring
this secret
your partners don't know your wife
doesn't even know what was the decision
to withhold it from your wife
yeah fear of shame um
that first couple days um i was just
thinking how like upset my parents are
gonna be when they find out about this
because i was the only
a child of my all my cousins in the
south that went to an ivy league college
and look what i threw it all away and
how would i tell my wife about this like
she doesn't know anything about these
trades i don't tell her in 2007 i'm
buying hilton and i don't talk about any
of that and so she's going to be shocked
like
she knows me as straight-laced tom
just
the guy she married and
it's gonna be shocking so how do i i
guess i'm thinking for a few weeks how
do i break the news to her and
gotta tell her at some point i gotta
tell somebody right
i went into st patrick's cathedral a few
days later and talked to a priest
and said this is what's happened and
i forgot what he said but
but i needed to talk to somebody i was
having panic attacks uh waking up
shortness of breath at night
uh it was bad it was uh
i was thinking about
maybe just
punching out like
going to the top of the building and
jumping off like it was pretty bad i had
struggled with depression in college
it was coming back pretty pretty hard so
and to be and to harbor that like alone
without support is pretty toxic right i
was going to put i was going to trap my
friends um and to tell me
the legal trades they had done
just to save myself so for the mistakes
i had made i was gonna go to colleagues
and friends and make them tell me
you could go to anybody on wall street
at the time and say tell me about that
trade that you traded illegally and
somebody would tell you something they
could record it so it was kind of
unlimited how i could help them
and i felt tremendous skill tremendous
regret
um
and uh i had some really bad days where
i'd go to the elevator and say
push the down button i'll push the up
button push the down button
go down go to work
just keep going so it was
it was tough for several weeks until i
told my wife and then that made a little
bit easier to talk to somebody about it
so
what was that conversation like uh it
was a friday night uh
i think we were gonna go out to dinner
uh we're just having a drink and
said so i gotta tell you something uh
about
something that's been going on and just
sort of
set back and
so the fbi approached me about some
trades i did
i'm going to help them out
across the line
and i think we're going to be okay
but
to work with them i'm going to have to
like take down some of our friends and
uh
it's a really crappy situation but it's
better than
our family being separated so
i'm gonna put our family over this and
hopefully i don't go to jail but i'm
gonna have to take down
uh some colleagues and people that have
been friends for years and uh it sucks
it's like i don't know what what you do
you don't
it's not like it was the mafia where i'm
not a rat and i'm not i'll go to jail
because i'm not gonna ride it's not i
wasn't even thinking about breaking the
law when this happened like it was i did
but it wasn't
like i got to decide friends or
colleagues and our family or colleagues
and
it's like okay i'll
i'll do what you guys want me to do as
long as it hopefully
keeps me out of jail how did she receive
that news
actually
she was pretty understanding like she
wasn't uh
she's going to process it to while and
said you know i would be really upset if
it was something you did to me or
something but it's not really that
you really you know screwed up but
uh we talked about it some more and then
she was just
absorbed it much better than i expected
um i told the fbi that i told my wife
and i said oh you know if we need to
talk to her let us know because this is
just breaks up a lot of marriages
no it's actually like we talked about a
lot and
decided like it's the best course of
action like a bad situation to do moving
forward so
if i didn't have her uh or if she had
reacted differently it would have made
it that much tougher yeah i would
imagine it does break up probably most
marriages right i mean she stood by you
you have two daughters right right that
was before she was pregnant so yeah
and just to put it into perspective i
mean you're 32 when this is gone
i was uh third i just turned uh
30 i was about to turn 31 but wow that's
july so still beginning my career
relative right right right yeah yeah
young man and it's over at that point
the career is over so i'm thinking 31
years old
done that guy i worked so hard my whole
life
public school in georgia
getting to this top school i threw it
all away in less than 10 years
unbelievable mm-hmm
but like and always an awareness of that
you you that you were responsible for
your own yes that was my own downfall
yep i took full responsibility i
didn't blame anybody else it was i made
those decisions and
there's other guys still working today
that did much worse than i did
they're still working that's just the
way
i happen to know this lady who they were
looking at and she knew raj and i was
just in that little
group there and right so when you when
you kind of look at the investment
community or the hedge fund community
you know how rampant would you say this
kind of illegal activity it was highly
rampant that the fbi was aware of it and
i could just say
give me a fund i'll get you a guy like
whatever you how however far they want
this to go and
they were just trying to lever up on raj
i think with other informants so
the ultimate goal is getting getting raj
right and so you're going to be like a
ladder on the on that on you know on the
way up to getting him so
so how does it begin like they pull you
you you go over to the fbi and meet them
like talk me through like the actual
process of beginning to wire top okay
and do all of this you know we meet a
few times they get the whole story in
all four trades
and it's kind of like you go over to the
fbi do you meet them in like
secret locations or we just
sat like it was a nice summer uh 2008 so
we just sat outside under a table and
okay boom give me your life story
up to where you did these trades
and then they said okay kind of like
whose head can you give us how helpful
can you be as an informant because
they're kind of skeptical i'm not
plugged into some of these um
information mafias like maybe some other
people are and
it was called the indian mafia clearly
don't fit that role but i was somehow
plugged into it so
they said who can you give us
and so i thought about
guys that i knew
were doing this as i said before as like
a business model like always doing this
and so i felt i justified my cooperation
and
bringing them down a little bit by
saying they're doing it all the time i
did it four times if i'm going to lose
my career over this
i'm going to help the fbi at least try
to rid some of the bad guys out right
they're doing it all the time
so i gave him a few names i thought i
could wear a wire on and we started
that day
with the first individual and
uh the wire is it's not like the god the
godfather where it's all around your
chest it's a little like blackberry
battery yeah so that's what i want to
know i want to know the actual like how
does it all work so uh
we talk about a situation to
um
to get um
the target into a conversation about an
illegal trade they did
which um
these were all people that were in the
same trades as me the one of the four
trades so
we could rehash like
um
when i told you about this and you
traded on it so
i'm already starting to
get these people going in the
conversation for something that i told
them
if they didn't know me they wouldn't
even be here so in this conversation so
getting them in that conversation
i need to get them to say that they knew
it was illegal or knew that we had
crossed the line and
uh the first individual
friend um
not just that not to just discuss an
illegal act but an acknowledgement i
need them to acknowledge it on the wire
yeah and so and the wire itself is it
like a little it's like taped on your
chest no it's like a little little one
remember like the little blackberry
battery rectangle things you just drop
it like in the pocket shirt pocket
you can just drop it in there so if it
were to fall out oh my blackberry
battery
uh so it wasn't like taped on the chest
or anything like that interesting
um and it's like a transmitter or is it
actually recording it on on recording it
device recording on the device and they
could play it back yeah
um and so uh i met with the first
individual that i knew that i told uh
some of these trades too and got him
into talking about it a little bit
he was very uh
quiet like
and so my first time they listened to it
and they said tom like you're talking
non-stop you have to let him talk like
i'm nervous so i'm just filling in the i
don't like the silence like i'm just
filling it in the silence like you have
to like
if he's gonna be silent for a man or two
just let him think about his answer and
don't talk so i kind of mucked it up a
little bit the first few times like
i'm just getting used to it i'm nervous
doing this and but you put it you put
this little thing in your chest pocket
right you go you have the conversation
and then you go handle over this device
right right
to the fbi right they listen to some
kind of drop arrangement or like how do
you just back into the they're usually
in the car outside and drop it off to
them and see it see tomorrow like what
time should we meet and but they're not
listening it's not transmitting so they
can't be listening
to it later afterwards
and they say kind of like
how i did you know and i wasn't good in
the beginning and they got better
uh when i'm doing it a few times
but at some point you get really pretty
good at this yeah yeah right because i
mean you you're basically
the work that you did
is responsible for
over two dozen prosecutions right right
so what i did um
what i did um specifically is i i did
this uh type of wire conversation with
maybe four individuals
but one or two of these individuals when
they were approached similarly to me
one of the individuals actually opened
this um
inside uh entire expert network network
uh of uh 20 individuals to the fbi so i
actually get credit
for opening up this network to them
because i introduced them to this person
so it's not like
the articles about me to say i did all
this stuff but i didn't even like really
know that that would happen until
i talked to my friend who then knew
right so so basically like you get
somebody on record
saying what they shouldn't and they bust
that guy and then they do the same thing
with that guy that they do and they're
just inching their way up yeah they look
at this guy and say can he help us or
should we arrest him if if he can't help
us
we're gonna arrest him he's going to
jail if he can help us
we'll approach him like we did myself on
the street and you have like like two
like sort of point people at the fbi
that you're interfacing with i mean do
you ever go in and meet with preet the
u.s attorney's office or not until later
after i hired a lawyer that i meet with
the ausa's and
so i'm just interfacing with um a few
people in the fbi
on the case and uh and meanwhile you
have no you're not having any
conversations about like look man are
you gonna still prosecute me or like no
i'm not thinking i'm not asking about
the outcome for me you're just basically
like whatever you need whatever you need
is my second job
i'm gonna be in california next week for
a stock conference i know this guy out
there who trades on all this stuff
i can
get him in a situation where he's gonna
tell me about a lot of oh
they were on the plane with me flying
out with me to california like
this sounds good um
so i got individual out there in a
conversation about
several stocks that he had traded
illegally
people that he was talking to inside
companies their names
and also like how he was hiding money in
some island or something
so i was talking to him for a while we
were in his car one night i was asking
him a lot of questions
he said tom are you wearing a wire or
something like why are you asking me all
these questions
is that the first time somebody yeah
sort of called you out a little that
time you think you were just getting too
comfortable with this role i think i was
a little less careful yeah i was just
peppering him with questions about oh
how do you because he knew that i had
come to him with some of some of the
trades in 2007 so tom kind of like
has his horses now too and so i'm trying
to get from him how do you hide the
money on these trades because i need to
know for myself because i have these
sources so i got to know in the future
how you do this and so i'm trying to
learn how to do all the illegal stuff
can you tell me
and he was kind of skeptical like
why are you asking me all these
questions like
so i'm just wondering for myself did he
shut down on you or you ultimately
ultimately answered them yeah
and there was another instance with an
individual in new york um the first
individual who i wore a wire on
who was skeptical it wasn't i wasn't
doing that well getting information from
him
and so he lives in greenwich connecticut
um and then one sunday he's like can you
come up
let's uh grab dinner
uh can you come up tonight so i took the
train up to greenwich from new york
and he picks me up in this car and he
says
uh let's go why don't we go swimming
i said okay he's like let's go to my
mom's house she has a big house so it's
this big empty quiet house in greenwich
he's got swim trunks for me he's putting
his swim trunks on he's like get changed
so clearly he wants to see if there's
something strapped to my chest right
right this is all artificed to like
figure out what's really going on yeah
yeah so he's skeptical i think of my
intentions and uh
he's like get changed i'm like i'll go
in the bathroom he's like no you get
changed in here like
so i'm there like naked getting changed
i'm able to say i go to the bathroom
real quick take it out of my pocket put
in my shorts
and get changed in the bathing suit
and then we go out
in the swimming pool and throw the
tennis ball it's very awkward very like
i'm kind of looking around it's a big
quiet house like is there a
ditch dug or something or what's right
is he gonna pull a gun on you or yeah
knock me out with a shovel or something
or is it yeah like i'm feeling pretty
like i never really felt like i was in
danger until this point like
he seems a little crazy this whole thing
and like we're in this big quiet house
and i don't know what's going on let's
go in the swimming pool i don't know
like so what's he what is he saying to
you and then so out in the swimming pool
he's talking about
have you been approached by the sec
i said no not the sec yeah
uh they don't tell them anything and
like okay
so make sure you're not wearing wire
like
stuff it's cool like whatever
so that was uh so i didn't recording the
conversation because it was back in my
shorts
is that like the
scariest moment in the wiretapping
career that was yeah yeah i wasn't uh i
was in other situations where i didn't
feel like i was talking with somebody i
would have been scared i think to go up
against a billionaire just
because of their means but right that
was the most scared i felt because it
was just a really awkward day and
i wasn't sure what he was getting at and
i could tell he wanted to see if i was
wearing a wire yeah that uncertainty of
not knowing like what exactly is going
on like that feeling of being out of
control right right
and i would imagine at this time you
know you sort of traded in this
whatever dissonance you were harboring
over making these illegal trades
initially and
you know whatever kind of like moral
consternation that caused you
for
this new level of anxiety and stress of
you know snitching on your friends and
your colleagues and and also this
you know idea of getting possibly caught
doing it and the danger that that's
putting you in right yeah and how is
this starting to affect your mental
disposition and you're still not good
like um
i'm not like having the should i go up
or down at the elevator thoughts anymore
i'm kind of past the suicidal thoughts
like i'm doing this
i'm just telling myself it's gonna it's
gonna help me in the end
um
and uh but at the same time
it's just tormenting to know i'm getting
these guys in situations that are going
to ruin their careers just like i did
and
i'm bringing them down from the stakes i
made which doesn't seem right but
and you can't really disclose who those
people are right right you can't really
talk about that but but
certainly you know this is what's
happened right like you have friends
that you have now sort of devastated
their lives right as a result of this
do you interact with them now like do
you see them do is there any
communication there's nothing i'm not
allowed to communicate with any of those
guys anymore uh
there's an individual whose name came
out later who i
reflect on conversations i had before
the fbi approached me who was really
peppering me with questions
so i think he was the instigator maybe
wearing a wire on me right but i don't i
don't feel uh
any ol or he had to do when he was in
the same situation i'm sure family or
friends
yeah and like he had to do what he had
to do against me and i had to do what i
had to do against the other guys and
and at some point
it's it becomes sort of public knowledge
that there's this guy out here you know
somewhere there's some guy who's ratting
right yeah he's called tipper x
and who is tipper x like who's this mall
right because right next to these guys
are going down all over the place
and i mean is there a concerted effort
in the community to like try to root
this guy out is that what is that what
going to greenwich was about and you
know
how close do they come to figuring out
that it's you uh nobody really did i
mean um
the tip or x thing started in 2009 in
october 2009 raj was arrested
and uh how did how so how did it happen
how did it finally get up to raw i mean
it was a result of all of these people
but you know ultimately you didn't have
any personal interaction with that
that's right
i was able to help them out with rumi
khan enough i think to get leverage on
her that she could really give them the
goods on raj and
i think there was other informants that
worked on raj when i understood it's
right but it wouldn't i mean raj is not
going down without the work that you did
right yeah because one of the main
people to bring him down was roomie
and for them to really get roomie to
cooperate they needed somebody else on
her so i was one removed
from raj
and then my cooperation on this
individual in california another
individual
opened up this entire insider trading
ring so if you look online there's an
infographic of like who knows who
there's the raj and then there's
thompson
i saw that who published that because i
remember seeing that along was that in
vanity fair there was something might
have been advantageous yeah i think it
was incredibly complicated yeah yeah
it was a big uh ring and so i was happy
and tipper x is like at the middle
between yeah right between it all right
right right right yeah and like
i was only talking did that come out
when you were in the middle of it though
i mean what was that like
okay so uh
i had started cooperating in july 2008
and then
january 2010 it was tipper x we figured
out who it is
and so i was given a heads up the day
before that article was coming out
um
every week there was a few names
released
and they said you're going to be the
only name released tomorrow so it's
probably going to be all over cnbc you
may want to
reporters are going to be calling you
coming to your house
but where does when does tipper x become
like vernacular like everybody people
are talking about october 2009 raj is
arrested um
the information is presented on him uh
by the feds like how
they think he's linked in this network
and then so some names are public some
names aren't
my name was still sealed at that point
so it was tip or x
so one of the articles said oh there's
this tip or x it seems to be very uh
important to this
uh prosecution and
uh who is tipper x and
so that was from just from october to
january right
and then i got the word that my name
would be unsealed um in january 2010.
and what is that decision about like why
did they have to unseal that it was just
part of uh i think as far as who they
were targeting for arrest that year
and what information needed to be made
public um it was just my time to be
unsealed
and i think they felt like i had already
done all i could so i mean obviously i
couldn't be unsealed if i was still
wearing wires so right so we've we've
used you uh yeah we've gotten out of you
what we're going to get out of you now
it's time to arrest you right basically
you know your name like yeah because up
to this point you weren't arrested yet
no no i didn't i wasn't processed until
um
well i was processed in december 2009 so
that was a month before
my name became public but that wasn't
really an arrest i turned myself in
you get fingerprinted you go through the
us marshall's office
you plead uh your honor i plead guilty
but turning yourself in i mean it's
at some point the fbi says you got to
come in now yeah yeah come and be
processed so that was just one day in
december
and and you're not like what do you mean
come on look what i did you're not
i'm really going to still get the felony
like yeah can't you just i never
and they
they say
yeah you're still still getting it maybe
you won't go to jail i mean along the
way though are they saying
wow you're really you know delivering
the kids here like i mean what is the
rel like do you befriend these guys in
the fbi what's that relationship like
it's a weird like stockholm system it is
yeah like sort of thing right yeah
they're saying doing a good job
uh what else you got
uh
always pushing you yeah yeah
and so at some point
after about four of these guys
uh i kind of said i don't
i don't have anybody i mean i think i've
done a lot i haven't talked to a lawyer
at that point to tell me yeah you've
done i can't believe you still hadn't
talked to a lawyer at all i just felt
like it would be in my best interest is
your wife saying i think you should go
no she's uh
she doesn't want to know too much about
it i think she just
you know uh
you know i tell her what i'm doing but i
don't tell her hey i wore a wire on this
guy and that guy just i don't want to
tell him
and then and did the fbi ever try to get
you to go do something that just was too
dicey where you just they had like a
little bit of panic and like backing out
of it they evaluated all the uh
potential risk of every person to be
wearing a wire on if it would be really
risky too risky to do and so they
invented that out pretty well
so they weren't going to make me uh
go sit with raj or something and right
that uh
i felt pretty comfortable other than the
situation with the swimming pool which
is just awkward
um and so yeah it was kind of like a
second job like
i joke with them a little bit about this
and that and oh i thought i was going to
fall out here and oh my neck was all red
here so maybe that person knew like yeah
so yeah you're having this collegial
relationship with these guys still going
down but it's like
right yeah that's that's wild now yeah
yeah so it's like um still got my job
through
um july 2008 to february 2009 so i'm
still going the office and there are no
they're none the wiser no nobody knows
what's going on
uh i'm not doing well at work like it's
a bad market i'm not picking good stocks
and i'm i'm just my brain doesn't work
at all so
by february 2009 my partner's like dude
you're not even like you're not here
like i don't know what happened to you
but i gotta let you go like
like i understand okay and at that time
i kind of think my name could be coming
out any day so i'm like so you so you
let them
let you go yeah yeah i was actually
gonna quit the day
that they fired me so i had actually
packed up all everything friday
sunday my partner sends me an email
saying don't come in monday you're done
we'll send you all the stuff home and
he's like where's all your stuff it's
gone
wow yeah so we it was weird because i
was gonna quit that monday just
the fun wasn't doing well i was so
stressed about this other thing i was
doing and
i just felt like
i couldn't handle going to work not
doing well and right
so so how much time between that and
when all of this goes public like your
name gets revealed you're arrested all
of that laid off february 2009 name is
public january 2010 so almost 11 months
later so what's that day like
so they tell me the night before um the
articles come out online that night
they're gonna be in the print papers the
next day tip rex unveiled tom harden
phones ringing off the hook
emails
one of the reporters i believe it was
from the new york times
uh i had a family blog about we just had
our daughter so i'm putting up cute
photos from my relatives in the south
he goes on and puts in the article tom's
wife's name is this his daughter's name
is this he's trying to get me to respond
it's pretty low um and you when the when
your name went public had you turned
yourself in already yeah so that was i
turned myself in december 2009 and my
name was public a month later i got you
all right so but that morning i wake up
for cnbc like preparing for i already
told i hadn't told my parents but i had
told my um father-in-law and
mother-in-law
and so i see this news about this
haitian earthquake and it's all haiti
earthquake nothing about tipper x so it
happened to be that day so the news
cycle saved you a little bit yeah yeah
um so it was uh and it was on the front
of c1 and wall street journal
tipper x revealed not hardened
so plenty of people read the wall street
journal never saw it because they're not
following the case so tip rex
skipped the article so
only a few people actually in the
industry even emailed me saying i saw
your name or hope you're doing okay wow
that's surprising a lot of people didn't
even see it because if you're not
following the case and my name is in the
headline right yeah
but you got to pick up the phone and
call your parents
uh i didn't i waited for a while and
unfortunately the way they found out was
my youngest brother was kind of
skeptical of me being out of work um
so my daughter was born october 2009
and so i said oh my
thing to everybody is i would be a state
i'm dad for a while figure out what i
want to do
my brother kind of skeptical oh you you
know i went to wharton and all this like
i don't think just
and so he's googling me
finds the story tipper x revealed
sends it to my parents
and my mom calls me um oh my god because
it says like he could go to jail for 20
years or whatever at its maximum like
i'm sure this is tearing up your
marriage i'm so sorry like
not the way i wanted to figure it out
i guess i was hoping that they would
never find out
right but that's like that's denial at
its finest yeah right yeah and i wanted
to tell them i kept saying next time
they're here
they were divorced but they would each
visit twice a year to see the baby and
i'll tell them in person i don't want to
say it over the phone it's easier to
explain in person
but it's that thing where
where the longer you wait the harder it
becomes and then eventually they find
out the wrong way yeah so that's just
like you couldn't get it together to
actually just do it right let them know
like over a year after my name was
published right they find out that
sounds pretty understanding from your
mom to say you know i'm concerned about
your marriage as opposed to like how
could you do this yeah like i saw like
you're gonna go to jail for a long
time sees uh
tom could go to jail for 20 years
because it's two counts and
but yeah like i'm so sorry you guys had
such a great marriage like i can't
believe it's going to be torn apart and
right
so i call her back and kind of have to
explain the situation and i'm so sorry i
didn't tell you before i didn't want to
worry like this and
um
and my and then i said please don't tell
dad i'll tell him
when he comes he's coming in a month to
visit i'll tell i want to tell him in
person
and she's like i had to tell your dad
like oh god like not the way i want it
to go down
and so i call him and
uh
she just doesn't understand like how
this could have happened like
how i could have crossed the line like
that it's not the boy that he raised and
like and he was pretty upset
uh and so it's over the phone too so
it's really hard to explain and
oh but everybody was doing it dad like
come on like right yeah now he doesn't
understand that like
uh
um
other friends of mine are just shocked
that i'm involved in this like this like
doesn't make sense like
tom's like
picks the stocks fundamentally like i
can't believe you
went overboard
what do you uh
like discern from that in terms of
you know how human behavior works like
if you can look at yourself and say you
know i didn't think that i was somebody
who would make that choice and
and my friends and my family members
didn't think that i was somebody who was
capable of doing that like what is you
know what is the lesson or what is the
forewarning i think anybody is capable
of it uh
anybody in my shoes at that time that
uh was getting caught up and seeing
everybody else make these trades in 2006
and kind of wanting a little bit of i
kept telling to myself in my head i'll
scrape some crumbs off the table it's
not going to hurt anyone like
it's a crime but there's no victims like
even at courts and seeing the judge ask
the prosecutor are there any victims
oh no your honor there's no victims like
sort of think this is a felony with no
victims is there anything else like that
like
other white collar crime made off
there's victims but
wow okay but it is in this country it's
felony and uh
i think anybody you know um
a few people have told me or i've heard
people
tell other people like oh i would never
cross that ethical line or
i think you don't know until you're
there and what you'll do and
how you'll justify it to yourself and
uh i'm kind of shocked that i got to the
point where i could be on the street
handing an envelope and kind of saying
this isn't me i'm not doing this like
but uh
i felt like a lot of me is still the
same person before all this happened so
it's uh
not like i was an evil guy and
uh
setting out in this big premeditated um
scam to try to do all these trades i was
just sort of answering the phone and she
said this and i placed the trade and
make the money and it
kind of fell on itself but uh
i don't think i think it could happen to
anybody if you're not
careful and if you're not
pretty well
ethically grounded uh
when you reflect back on it
i mean what are the you know how do you
feel about yourself like what are the
emotions that you experience
um
uh i'm often angry uh because
uh there's still guys working that did
it much worse than me and they never
were just in they were just in the right
web of people that were not in the radar
so i feel sometimes resentment like wow
they're at the their careers now they're
37 and
making all this money and
that's not fair because
resentment excuse me yeah the resentment
and
at the same time
not glad it happened but i've been able
to spend this time my daughters are five
and three with them
a lot of my buddies live on a plane the
nanny raises the children which
everybody has to do what they have to do
for their family but
to have this time with them has been
great so there's been some positives
um
you know i was 215 pounds
at the end of my career and to find
running and to get in shape and right i
want to get into that i mean i can't
imagine you were 215 yeah you're a
beanpole yeah you know
um
yeah so
so tip rx goes public
raj gets toppled you're in the news
you're in the public eye
uh
it's all out your parents are finding
out right and you're a persona non-grata
right and you're unemployed right
so how do you wake up the next day and
move forward like how do you how do you
figure out
how you're going to start to piece your
life back together i've been sentenced
you're a felon you've been out of work
for quite a while right out of work at
least over a year then
i'm trying to figure out i'm sending out
resumes non-stop but it's a non-starter
anybody that calls me back
you know you have to fill out the
application have you ever been convicted
of a felony yes
but please still talk to me
not at that job market though like
that's a non-starter
so
all the 2010
resumes are going out um
any inroads that i'm making pretty close
to jobs okay let us know when you get
sentenced and at the time i'm thinking
it's always a few months away
and it keeps getting pushed out 2011
2012 2013 up to 2015.
so i'm not i can't piece together
it's still a problem now what's my next
career going to be
uh
and uh
nothing's happening because i understand
like if
if i'm a potential employer this guy's
come to me
with felony and maybe a guy but i can't
hire this person because
if i'm it's sentencing oh tom now works
with xyz oh they're in the news like
also if anything ever happened the
employer's on the hooks yeah you know
why did you you knew you hired this guy
right i can sell them i think i'm not
going to jail but they don't know that
yeah
yeah so uh so nothing
nothing moved on that has moved on that
needle from 2010 to 2015. i mean
and at some point uh running comes into
the picture yeah um
so
uh
i'm i'm going to stay at home dad 2010
putting on weight um just not eating
well
not sleeping well
just depressed i guess um but
depression's like like not just like a
cavalier
depressed like like clinically depressed
i think so i didn't talk to anybody i
probably should have talked to a medical
professional and
at least uh dealt with it that way but
it's depressed um
got up i think i was 190 at the start of
2010 i got up to 215 by 2011.
um i decided um
when i was just sitting on the couch and
eating junk food or like uh just not
exercising just my metabolism finally
caught up like i was a soccer player my
whole life and until like age 30
i stopped exercising at age 18 didn't
make the team at penn so
didn't matter until i was kind of 30 31
typical guy and then by 30
33
i just
carry my daughter around
out of breath
like
end of 2010 i had a pulmonary embolism
scare
where i couldn't breathe and had to go
to the hospital my wife had to come home
my mother-in-law had to watch my
daughter
and then i went into january 2011 for my
first animal physical since age 18
typical guy didn't go to the doctor
unless something was wrong
he's like you know
uh
you're uh the bmi thing you're
obese overweight on the line
what do you mean like i'm a skinny guy
like
no you're not like technically obese
you're technically obese because 510 215
was right on that line
like oh my god like he's like you know
i could tell you how it's going to go
down you're going to be
40 and getting all the prescription
medication for high blood pressure and
it runs in my family and
uh cancer has been in my family and this
is this is what i see like you're going
to have the sleep apnea probably when
you're 39 40 41 will you the machine
scaring me
which is good
um
and then uh
my wife as i said was a swimmer
in college and she had
run a few times a week and kind of did
the 5k here and there and
and so i told her after that like i'm
going to sign up for the gym she's like
oh it's january yeah of course you are
yeah
january you and everybody else
so
i said no i'm going to
sign up and see if i can just start
walking a little bit and
try to get some of this weight off and
she said you know in april one of the
towns next to us there's this 5k like
maybe just try to get up to running
three miles or something like that so
that's a great thing to put on the
calendar like sure i'll try that and
then
i kind of got where uh you know the
first 10 pounds get down to like 200 and
i can actually like run a mile and then
get outside a little bit and
run two miles and
feeling better and then i've complete
you know i break 30 minutes in my first
10 5k or whatever and
feeling some sense of accomplishment
like okay i've lost 20 pounds now and
starting uh my knees aren't hurting
anymore and then
kind of start to get the bug like what's
next like a 10k something like that like
okay the 10k let's do that next month
and like get up to six miles and that
was
terrible because like that was twice the
amount i ever run and
what's after that like the half marathon
like i'll just sign up for one
i'd never run further than like seven
miles you know in the half marathon like
i walked like the last five miles but
whatever i accomplished i
did it and
uh
started just losing more weight so i was
done like probably 30 pounds by that
point was feeling pretty good and
still
kind of eating whatever because hey i
was running so
running to eat
and uh
did the half marathons for a while and
then
kind of got pretty good at the half
marathon where i could thought maybe
that half marathon time would translate
to my boston qualifier time with the
marathon
and then decided early 2013 to sign up
for my first marathon
and train for that um and i got
uh the 310 was the beq when i got to
308.
uh the problem was uh the bombings
happened in boston that year so
everybody in the world who was a 230
marathoner signed up for 2014 and right
the cutoff was eight seconds faster than
what i had run so
didn't make it into eight seconds so i
decided to run the marathon in the year
it was like the toughest cutoff ever oh
wow so i missed it by eight seconds 2014
and then missed it again by like six
seconds for this year oh you did so i i
i didn't really improve that much i had
a bad race the next year
and then so i did um
so 2013
first marathon was in uh may
and then i went uh to the library to
start reading running books and then uh
eat and run it's there and right read
that and like
sort of said like oh what you ah what
you eat affects how you feel like wow
like what a revelation this guy has run
all these you know 165 miles in 24 hours
one of these ultras and
he's eating uh um
it's called vegan or something like that
and told my wife she said what is that
like i don't know it's like
yeah some of those recipes looks like
scott had some recipes in this book and
like i'll try that and this and that and
i brought it back to the library and the
librarian's like there's this other book
like oh this guy's vegan too
yeah i'm always the follower
if you like this you might like this
yeah yeah yeah
uh so read your book and uh
like i just told my wife like so i just
there's the only two books in ultra
running in the library and both these
guys have the same type of diet that's
like right do we interest do the math
yeah yeah
um and so
i looked into it and then uh looked
online and there was the rips book like
28 days to get there i'm like this seems
pretty doable like
chick the dairy and then the chicken and
like the meat was easy but the dairy is
tough and yeah to get rid of and so it
was definitely harder so you did the
engine two things i did the engine two
for uh the four four weeks and got
through it and so what was the so you
you lost a bunch of weight doing just
the running but then what was the
difference when you decided to like uh
adopt that i just started running as
many miles as i could every week and
like it wasn't affecting me so uh
i got up to 55 miles a week um when i
was still eating meat in that marathon
my first marathon
i got up to 70 miles a week in the fall
marathon when i had been
i would say like 80 plant-based on the
weekend if we went out to dinner at a
restaurant i'd reward myself with
whatever
and then uh in early 2014 i started
running like 100 miles a week and i was
recovering
i was being smart i was you know like 80
easy twenty percent hard five days easy
two days hard
so i wasn't ever doing the training but
the mileage was going nuts like no coach
would ever have told me to go from 55 to
100 peak in a year
but i was feeling
really good and
ended up breaking three hours in the
marathon last fall
and uh
i still felt like i was in better shape
than that but whatever marathon's really
hard to predict and yeah
and so now this year um
i just ran like 130 miles last week oh
wow and like i feel fine like i don't
know i explained like
but
i i i i found an elite marathoners plan
like i think i can do this like if i
wake up early enough
um
and so
i don't want to do a marathon now i'd
like to wait and give it a year to see
if i could do the next 10 minute
increment down to below 250.
so i found um i was looking for ultra
marathons and
you know in uh california iran mountains
are down mountains in new york new
jersey it's like you run around these
timed events right
right right right right so i found this
uh race and i'd never done an ultra and
it said 12 hours or 24 i signed up for
12.
and then i told a buddy
i don't know if you know i'm heated up
at five last year crystallars uh i know
the name it was two guys from new york
today last year
i don't know him personally and so i
sent him um he's like what are you
running i'm like i just i'm going to go
up to like 150 miles this spring i think
i think i can do it he's like oh you
have to run the 24 hour not the 12 hour
like oh so yeah
so i emailed the race director just last
week and i'm doing the 24. wow when is
that
may 16th and if you run 135 miles you
qualify for the national team
and like i think i can do it like i've
never run i mean
raced above a marathon but i mean it's
probably i probably hopefully will do it
my life but maybe not this time but
i have this ridiculous goal and i really
think like i can run
i can do it like i don't know i can
explain
uh
uh
i'm running all these miles but it's
right it's working i don't know well the
biggest difference between what you were
doing before with your running and what
you're doing now is what you're eating
yes right and so you're experiencing
this extraordinary recovery time you're
ramping up i mean you're doing there are
very few people on the planet that are
running more miles a week than that
right you know so you're you're peaking
out yeah i mean there's not much more
you could do no i mean i don't want to
do more because then
i'm doing doubles every day and i can't
do triples because i have the kids
right
i don't want to you didn't run here from
new jersey
didn't do that but uh
i plan to get up to 150 at my peak week
and i think i can manage that with um
friday saturday sunday marathons
back to back to back and i think if i
can do that then i feel good about
running the 135 but
it may not happen this time but i think
i can get there and it's just so nice to
have this crazy goal
that only like 15 guys ran that much
last year and
it's funny like the trail ultras in the
flat ultra is a completely different
world like the guys that ran these
flat ultras big mileage aren't the same
names as the trail ultras yeah it's
different it's a different sport kind of
you know like what killing journey does
yeah timothy olsen like you know they're
jackrabbits right you know it's a
different thing right and so around new
jersey it's like
i'm going to go out to the state
fairgrounds run a mile and get heckled
by people eating funnel cake like why
are you exercising my friends will be
out there with their pbrs
what are you doing what are you running
from there's a certain like mental
discipline with that though because you
have to combat that like you know the
the inevitable like the repetitive
boredom of it yeah yeah that makes it
different
um
but
you know that's rather extraordinary so
i'm interested in in exploring like the
relationship between you know the
running and the diet and
kind of how you're navigating this
purgatory that you're in right now so
and how that's you know sort of a self
um
yeah so my diet uh i went basically all
plant-based last year um
running more miles
uh the part of my life that's still a
problem is the employment
part i've got
sort of uh physical taking care of
emotional is pretty good
mental
it's all pretty good now but it's just
uh
not it's not where it should be but the
main holdback of my life right now is
employment i'm just hoping
it sounds silly but i'm hoping if i keep
running something good will happen but
uh but how is the running like helping
you like emotionally like
with everything it's great um
kind of getting out um
for like an hour and a half in the
morning and an hour at night and
uh i don't know if i'm it's not i don't
know if i'm meditating but i'm kind of
getting into a zone where i look down at
five miles go by and it feels like five
minutes
and uh that active meditative state i
think so yeah i'm running a lot of the
loops so i have a lot of half mile loops
to get ready for the mile loop race
and just not worrying about traffic or
stop lights i'm just going and going and
going
um
it's like uh
very therapeutic um and so i
come into the craving the endorphins now
and
um it's really helping me deal with um
the situation of having some uncertainty
or major uncertainty now to what my next
career is going to be
i feel conflict a little bit like maybe
i should just be running singles and
spend the other part of the day
looking for work or something but
um
i feel so good doing this uh
i hope it's going to lead to something i
hope my next career has something
running related
to it um and uh it's my kids think it's
pretty cool like they i want to set a
good example for them and
to be fit and to have goals and
uh everybody i tell this goal to now
they can't i mean most of them aren't
runners and they just like
but but because you're unemployed like
this gives structure to your debt it
does yeah and it's
in a sense of purpose outside of just
family you know right child rearing
um
that i would imagine kind of anchors
here it does yeah i can uh
like by 7am i've already accomplished
like a lot like for the day and
uh it gets my day going and uh
you know i'm up uh 4 30 and
uh have my herba mate tea and uh
i just uh
spent a few minutes just uh drinking my
tea and then uh
my wife goes out for her run or i go out
for mine and it's just a nice quiet time
and
uh and then at 7 a.m i've i've run 10 or
15 miles or whatever and i feel like
i've accomplished something for the day
and
it keeps me really uh grounded and uh
ready to think about uh
what to do that day
so the events of your life and these
decisions that you've made have
led to a place where
you know the life that you're leading
couldn't be more distinct from the life
of the
the hedge fund manager right like the
idea of getting up and quietly sipping
your yerba mate in a meditative state is
not it's not you know it's not what a
hedge fund manager does right so
you're
you know i i see it as
you know quite frankly it's like a it's
a spiritual evolution yeah i really look
at it like that and this is happening
for
a reason whatever that reason may be and
now you're in this place where
you've been compelled to look at
yourself in the mirror and your and
evaluate you know these choices that
you've made and adjust accordingly and
now you're making these different
choices about your daily lifestyle
habits that
have kind of crafted a completely
different individual right
so
when you look back on your former life
like if somebody said to you you hear
you know what i know you're a felon but
you know
forget about the legalities of it like
in a utopian world they said you know
what here's your here's your job back at
this really nice hedge fund i could do
it yeah i don't think i'll ever be able
to take a desk job anymore
um
i say that but if it's the best thing
for my family and i get
you know a job i can't turn down i'm
going to have to figure out how to work
the writing around it and
but i can't imagine going back and doing
what i was doing before
with all the other stuff aside like if
i'm just doing legitimate work and
back of the firm i can't because
just because i'm a new person now in
this um what is the difference i found a
passion like uh
um
i was just kind of going about my day
um you know i guess my passion changed i
was passionate about the market i miss a
lot of the people i worked with
and now i have something new that's come
out of this uh
last couple years and
i'm just not
into the same things
i was in before i've kind of found a
new um
new passion in life uh
i guess it's not something i needed to
go to business school for but that's
can you find gratitude in that
uh
i think so yeah um
but you're not quite there yet not quite
there yet i'm not uh
do you think that you'll look back
someday and think
i'm grateful that all of that happened
because now i'm living this completely i
hope to be there i hope to be there
i'm not there you're not yeah yeah i
have still have a lot of regret and i
still feel bad about what i had to do
but at the same time
i'm not at that dark place of looking at
the elevator button and
that's all behind me and
uh
my children know who i am i'm like i'm
like uh
president of the pta at the preschool
organizing the fundraiser sorry i feel
like super dad yeah doing that thing
with all the people and the community
volunteering right right recognized by
the community and uh
so most of those people i mean they
still even know with other articles that
come out they're not going to know about
and if they do
i mean if somebody has a problem with it
it's their problem like i
i guess it's it's lucky also that your
daughters are so young that yeah it's
not you know by the time they're of the
age to understand everything like this
will be you know
quite distant yeah i think so i always
think about how am i going to tell them
when obviously they're too young but
uh
it's a good lesson for them i guess like
have you thought about like how you
would
talk to them about what happened how
that conversation's going to go when
they're i haven't thought about it yet
because
they just know daddy's at home mommy
works
and i say daddy used to work and they
laugh
daddy's daddies don't work or daddy's
work but you don't work you stay with us
um
i haven't thought about how i try to
explain that to them yet i just try to
set a good example now and
hope they uh
grow up and make better decisions than i
made and
i was talking to a priest about it at a
pretty low time in 2008 in our church
and he said
tom 99 of your life you did the right
thing one percent in your life you did
something bad don't let one percent
define
your life i thought that was like pretty
good advice uh
don't let
four decisions you made
getting caught up in things and having
the lapse in judgment
define uh and it defined my life i think
2008 up until when i started running and
now
i'm not letting those decisions define
my life it's still a major hindrance on
finding my next
career and where that's gonna go
what's the uh what's the what's the
dream job then like the realistic dream
job
i'd like to have some combination of
maybe a
running coach and maybe getting my
plant-based nutrition certificate from
cornell or some that combination like
that but
i'll have to run the 135 before i'm
legitimate
i haven't done anything yet i think it's
a pretty realistic goal for you yeah i
think so you know yeah i mean there's
nothing stopping you from getting the
certificate right right and do that
anytime yeah so
um
yeah i think that's uh what i'd like to
be doing um and just uh i've always
wanted
like enjoyed helping people i volunteer
at the church when i can and move
clothes around and
uh
it's like i know you're so familiar with
just the epidemic that this country has
with obesity and
if i could help people out and i try to
lead by example i don't try to push this
dialogue my wife doesn't do it my kids
don't do it
i just try to lead by example and say uh
hey i'm not getting injured maybe it's
because of what i'm eating
and so uh
cause i i have like a little running
club and nobody runs more than maybe 70
miles and
what are you doing like right
actually why are you doing elite
marathon or mileage
i'm able to do it i don't know like it's
just
uh
maybe i'm built for this type of event
or something i don't know but
it's uh
it's going to lead to something i hope
if you could go back and
greet yourself on your first day at the
hedge fund
what what would the advice be that you
would give the younger version of
yourself
uh with everything that you've
you know
experienced right
uh
would be uh you know
do the right thing uh stick to stick to
your fundamental research but also
follow your passion in life uh
um
and so i think but you wouldn't have
even known
at that point
you wouldn't know
what your passion was you would have
said you would have identified your
passion as just
yeah like basically doing what you were
doing right right and it took it took it
took
an extraordinary dismantling of your
life
for you to get to a place where
you could even begin the process of
trying to truly explore what your
passion might be or who you really are
you know outside of this
you know this world this costume that
you're putting on every day it's a tough
um
it's a tough position because i uh
somebody asked me are you happy or not
happy but are you glad this all happened
and there's a lot of positives that come
out of it but
i'm not glad to have a felony like
nobody would say that so
um
if i could go back and talk to my 30
year old self 29 year old self
um yeah i could say oh
she's gonna call you in 2007. don't
don't do those trades but
i think anybody at the time
would have been very tempted to do what
i did and uh
i don't know if anything i say now would
have changed what happened
when it did
disappointed myself but i'm also i can't
keep flogging myself i just have to move
on the past in the past and
uh
you know it's
things are starting now and
just have to look to the future and
hopefully peace out
uh
i'm gonna make a living and help support
my family uh
the stay at home dad thing is fine but
i've gotta
we can't survive on that forever so
we've gotta right right do something and
my wife has been incredibly supportive
let me run these crazy miles and
seeing it's my passion but
uh
i don't know i mean it's not
it can't
something has to fall into place where i
can
it's up to me to figure out yeah i need
to do and i i keep i guess
hoping something falls in my lap and
my uh
unsolicited opinion
on it
is uh
i don't know i mean my i think that that
we're here on earth to grow we're here
to have experiences to learn from them
and to grow from them
and to the extent that
um
you can take what has happened to you
and find a way to
translate that
into your own personal growth
and then use that to be of service to
other people the more that you can get
out of yourself and your predicament
and try to
be of counsel or be of service through
large actions and small to your kids to
your wife to your community
potentially to
you know the investment community in
whatever way
you can identify
the more that you are in that place
truly in that place of just
here to serve
then the details of how you're going to
make a living and what happens next i
think we'll sort themselves out right
now i mean i agree i've uh
um
reading jab jab uh
oh gary vaynerchuk
along the same other thinking i have
right now i just have to
piece that together and other than other
than your wife and your priest are you
getting any other are are you able to
talk to anyone else to help you process
through
all of this uh i haven't talked to
anybody else um
i thought about life coaches and that
type of thing but i don't know if that's
kind of skeptical of that maybe i could
be a life my wife could put together a
pretty good syllabus for you of
spiritual rather than reading garyvee
right let's get you on some spiritual
texts and help you like really like sort
of emotionally and spiritually navigate
this because i think that i think that
you can come out the other side of this
and my hope for you
and my expectation for you
is that you can get to a place where you
truly at your core can look back on this
and and be grateful that it happened for
you for yourself for your kids and for
your family that'd be great i want to be
there too and i'm not
there yet but i hope to be
maybe you can come back and tell me
about it when you get there that'd be
great yeah
let's do it yeah cool man well thanks
for talking to me thanks rich i wish you
the best thank you and i appreciate you
coming out today no problem thanks for
having me all right man peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you